welcome back so we're talking about
neural networks which are very
expressive machine learning
architectures for arbitrary function
approximation and we're talking about
the architecture kind of how they work
what the different types are and what I
want to talk about now is why they are
having this huge resurgence why our
neural networks everywhere now when
before 2012 they weren't even mentioned
in the top top 10 algorithms for example
so something big happened in 2012 that
put neural networks back on the map and
I'm gonna walk you through kind of what
that was and what the new capabilities
are and where these are going okay so
we've known for a long time or at least
hypothesized for a long time and this
goes back to the neuroscience that if
you had deeper bigger neural networks
like our brain has a ton of neurons and
many many many layers of connections
maybe you could get more expressive
better neural networks and back in the
olden days we didn't have enough data
and big enough computational
architectures and good enough algorithms
to train these kind of deep big neural
networks and so that's really what
changed in 2012 with this image net data
set that I'm going to tell you about so
what you want to do is train this big
deep neural network but you need there's
a lot of degrees of freedom there's a
lot of free numbers free parameters you
have to tune and so you need a lot of
training data to fit those models in
addition if I want to be able to
reliably know what is a dog and how is
that different than a cat and how is
that different than a pickup truck I
need a lot of examples of all of those
labeled data and this was very expensive
labeled data set in 2012 this image net
data set with millions of labeled images
so you might have a thousand thousands
of images of a dog that are labeled dog
and thousands of images of cats and
trucks and cars and broccoli and
everything you can imagine everything
you've seen practically is in this image
net database labeled images and that in
combination with increasingly powerful
computational algorithms so
kind of GPU graphics processing unit
computers that could do very very
massively parallel computations on
multiple cores allowed us both the
computational hardware the architecture
the label data to start training these
deep more expressive networks and so
that was kind of the birth or the
rebirth of deep learning and since then
it's taken over many many many aspects
of our machine learning and in our daily
lives from Alexa and Siri to image
classification in Google and Facebook to
much broader reaching applications and
I'll also point out that there is a huge
development of open source software so
the industrial investment by big tech
companies billions of dollars of
research and and development of open
source software and kind of community
driven research and software has really
also contributed to driving this so you
have your big label data unprecedented
volumes of quality data massive and
increasing architectures for processing
this data and training these algorithms
which facilitate deep deeper larger
architectures and the software is
getting much better to to train this
also in the in the olden days you'd have
to program the framework to train these
algorithms and now what tends our flow
and PI torch and caris it's much much
easier to do this with with your data
with new data ok and so this is
ubiquitous it's everywhere in facial
recognition surveillance image
captioning this is kind of incredible
you can actually label images now this
was you know even a decade ago we
thought this might be impossible this is
something only humans can do but that's
not true now you can you can image
caption not always perfect you know this
is a cat sitting on a couch with a
remote control not really this was one
of my favorites a horse standing in the
middle of a road where's the horse but
it's still pretty good
of course you know images are not
trivial there's still canonical things
that machine's get confused about I love
the you know Chihuahua blueberry muffin
it's easy for us to tell or is it fried
chicken dog is fun but overall the
performance is getting you know at or
above human level recognition in a vast
array of tasks especially in image
recognition natural language processing
speech recognition things like that this
is pretty cool this was pretty recent
where a set of researchers are using
these generative networks these gans to
start doing you know generative models
so from one picture of the Mona Lisa
they were able to make these very
realistic lifelike sequences that look
like she's speaking and interacting in
the real world
so these generative models you might
have seen them if you put a picture you
know there's websites you can upload a
picture and it'll make it look like van
Gogh painted it that's this kind of
technology but the implications are
pretty profound I mean this is gonna
change perhaps you know our society at
the core if you what if you can't trust
the news you're seeing because people
can generate videos that look just as
real as the real world what if you can't
trust what your politicians are saying
maybe you couldn't trust what your
politicians were saying already but what
if you don't even know if it was then
saying it I mean this changes a lot so
there's a bunch of really exciting
applications maybe I can generate new
new airfoil designs or new automotive
designs or new engineering designs in
general that I've never seen before that
there's really cool applications of that
but there's also serious kind of
concerns that we should be thinking
about in these generative models so
again neural networks in general can be
very expressive but you need lots of
training data to you know in general to
train them that is computationally
expensive so we have these GPU and
actually new Tenzer processing unit CPU
architectures lots of open source
software and so it's kind of this
culmination of industrial you know tech
investment big label datasets and
improving computational hardware that's
really driving these incredible advances
okay so we'll talk a little bit about
kind of caveats
I really should there's a cautionary
tale about when you can use a neural
networks when you should use neural
networks if this isn't a cautionary tale
enough okay thank you